L'idée m'est venue, un soir,
de concevoir un produit technologique personnel
Qu'on ne met pas sur son bureau ou dans sa poche
Mais qu'on porte à son poignet
Un matin, il y a un collègue qui est arrivé avec une montre Samsung
et là, Tim il l'a vu et il a dit : "On fait pareil !"
Et du coup... On a fait pareil.
Apple Watch, connectée à votre iPhone
vous permettra de gérer votre quotidien d'une manière intuitive.
La montre elle est reliée directement en Bluetooth ou WiFi...  A votre portable
Du coup... ça va pomper la batterie de l'iPhone !
Déjà que de base... ça tient pas !
Pour brancher votre Apple Watch, nous avons imaginé un moyen facile
Recharger votre montre c'est extrêmement simple.
Et c'est surtout tous les jours !
Parce que la batterie d'Apple Watch ça ne tient pas la journée, nan!
Et c'est pas le même câble... C'est celui-là... Non c'est pas cel...nan, ça c'est l'ancienne..euh..
Apple Watch mesure précisément vos activités sportives
Quand je fais du sport,
La montre va m'indiquer le nombre de calories que j'ai brûlé
Le nombre de kilomètre que j'ai parcouru
Et même mon rythme cardiaque.
C'est génial ! Quoi !
Par exemple, vous avez parcouru combien de kilomètres récemment ?
Mais moi je ne fais pas de sport !
Par contre, j'ai Mickey qui m'indique l'heure avec ses bras.
Nous avons développé un tout nouveau moyen pour vous connecter intimement avec les autres
Comme attirer l'attention d'un de vos amis avec une simple pression qu'il ressentira dans son poignet.
Je l'utilise très régulièrement avec mes amis.
Je m'en sers jamais.
Je m'en sers jamais...  C'est limite chiant !
Ah ben voilà c'est encore, bah c'est encore Tim ... Il y a que lui qui l'utilise
Siri, est-ce que tu peux dire a Tim d'arrê...
Pourquoi ça lance le calendrier ?
Attends je vais lui envoyer un... Ah ben j'ai plus de batterie.
Vous pouvez également envoyer un dessin, que vous faites directement avec votre doigt
Ah ils l'ont laissé ça ? Les mecs j'avais dit qu'on le mettait pas ça...mais non mais...
On peut pas...on peut pas dessiner sur 3 centimètres, comme ça, regardez, j'essaye de faire un arbre par exemple
Voilà... Et voilà ! Et voilà ! On peut pas ! C'est super dur !
On peut également les imprimer, ça représente un arbre...
une femme, un poiss...un poisson
Tiens, on va voir si ça l'amuse ... Hé, Tim !
C'est marrant ou pas les pulsations ?
Nous avons créé 3 collec...
Nous avons créé 3 collections distinctes.
D'abord, l'Apple Watch, disponible à partir de 649€
L'Apple Watch Sport, dès 399€
Et bien sûr, nous avons pensé a toutes les bourses
Si vous êtes très, très très très riche, nous avons l'Apple Watch Edition, allant jusqu’à 18 000€
18 000€ ?!
C'est super cher de ouf !
Non franchement, 18 000€... Sachant que l'année prochaine on sort l'Apple Watch 2 !
Donc re-18 000€...
Pour 18 000€ en plus, on peut s'acheter d'autres trucs
On peut s'acheter une... Une voiture , une Golf, une petite Golf ! 5 portes, familiale.
Vous pouvez également, personnaliser votre montre
On a un petit fond de commerce en campagne pour 18 000€
Envoyez des émoticones animés
Une place de parking en Bagnolet. Pour vous, 18 000€
Grâce à un bouton, retrouvez vos contacts préférés.
25 iPhone 6 16 giga, j'ai calculé.
Vous pouvez aussi échanger votre pulsation cardiaque avec vos amis
Tiens ! Je viens de recevoir le pouls de mon ami Johnny
Il est plutôt élevé !
Comment ça licenciement ? Comment ça licenciement? Vous vous êtes trompés...
C'est pas possible, ça peut pas être moi, non mais attendez ça fait trop longtemps que je suis dans la boîte !
Vous n'avez pas le droit ! VOUS N'AVEZ PAS LE DROIT !
Nous sommes arrivés à un produit d'une rare intensité technologique
Mais ceux qui en parlent le mieux, ce sont les utilisateurs eux mêmes.
Quand Apple a annoncé l'Apple Watch, j’étais le premier à la pré-commander. Voilà ...
Et vous pensez quoi des gens qui disent que les fans d'Apple sont prêt à tout acheter
Même un débouche-chiotte Apple ?
Attends il y a un débouche-chiotte Apple qui est sorti ?
Et on m'a pas prévenu ?
Moi j'ai tout, j'ai ça ! J'ai une tablette ! J'ai tout, c'est quoi?
Toi tu l'as ?
C'est quoi c'est 500€? 600€?
attends elle est où ma thune là ? Putain !
Elle est où ma thune ?!
Nous sommes vraiment fiers de ce produit
Car chez Apple, ce que nous voulons faire
c'est rapprocher les individus qui ont pu être séparés par la distance ou les événements.
Se sentir proche ensemble, avec un produit simple et personnel
Et relier toutes ses personnalités pour créer un futur meilleur
*snif* Désolé, c'est l'émotion...
* Se mouche *
Désolé
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, merci au chinois d'avoir conçu cette fausse montre Apple Watch
à 40 dollars sur eBay, le bouton sur le côté ne tourne même pas
Je ne sais même pas ce qui est écrit dessus ... Hein ... Si quelqu'un lit le chinois
Je remercie également Julien Josselin, Natoo et Kemar pour leur participation à la vidéo
et je vous remercie d'être 7 millions d'abonnés ... C'est un truc de ouf ...
On fête ça très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo
Ciao !